he's the Commissioner of the NBA Adam
Silver who joins us this morning
commissioner how are you I'm good good
morning Dan uh what kind of basketball
game did you have growing up uh not much
I I enjoyed playing but I mainly a
playground player if you played against
Commissioner Stern who we would I would
easily look he's got a bad wish I just
saw him I think he's got a bad wheel
he's I he's been limping around a little
bit lately he think he's gotta have his
knee operated on again so I would
definitely take him what about in his
prime you know I know you know he used
to brag in the office about these
lawyers leagues he used to play in so I
don't know I could just see him that old
Mark Jackson move backing me down
backing me down whether it's a delicate
load there's a Dellavedova quality to
Commissioner Stern as one as well you
know that the gritty guddi guy on the
court he strikes me as he's not gonna
give in hey you're right it would be
quote all right I would win them a
couple things here how close of and I
are you keeping on vegas with what
happened with the NHL I'm i am keeping a
close eye on it i mean it's a market
that we've been playing our summer
league in for at least the last ten
years so we've been there every July you
know I've been to the new arena that AEG
just built there and I think it too it's
a great market I we're not in expansion
mode so we're not it's not something
that was even thinking about right now
but it's based on what i've read the NHL
is on their way and even our old owners
the Maloofs seem to be involved the old
owners the sacramento kings and so I you
know I I know that the people of Vegas
love their sports I think one of the
issues is the size the television market
I mean that matters a lot more for the
NBA NHL that went for the NFL for
example because all the NFL games are
national and I know that's something
that they continue to study and it's
it's not it's it's a a different kind of
market when it comes to season ticket
holders because at least in our league
usually the bar for success for our
teams is a is that having at least ten
thousand season ticket holders and my
sense is Las Vegas may not be as
conducive to the traditional model for a
team where you build it on season ticket
holders as opposed to having to resell
20,000 seats every night but but on the
other hand they have this huge base of
tourists and especially I know for our
league one of the things we've looked at
for vegas is number of international
tours that come to that town and as we
get more popular in asia and europe you
know and in other parts of the world a
lot of people from those markets are
constantly traveling into vegas so that
would be one of the attractions as well
so i'm going to the commissioner adam
silver joining a Stan Patrick show
you're going to be in Cleveland tonight
absolutely you were you sitting I am
sitting usually we sit about 12 rows up
or so usually in the center sort
generally our seats are facing the
benches sort of Fame at the same angle
that the television viewer gets sort of
sitting up behind where the announcer
said so no courtside seats or no
courtside no court said although I love
sitting courtside I don't often get to
do that you know I've always said i
think the courtside cdma is the best
seat in all sports we mean I think in
part because you can feel the game in a
different way you obviously can hear
that the exchanges between the players
you know from sitting down on the floor
when you've been covering the games I
will say though when you're up a little
bit sometimes it gives you a little bit
better angle I've noticed that most of
the scouts in the NBA tend to sit up a
little bit not up in the rafters right I
hear the NHL scouts it because they want
to be able to see the full ice I find of
your up you know 10 15 rows it helps you
get a little bit better court sense when
you see um how the plays are unfolding I
don't know if you like I could I have
good seats I have nothing to complain
about good I don't know if you followed
Reggie Miller when he tweeted out that
he suggested that draymond Green doesn't
get suspended if the series was tied at
two instead of a 3-1 Golden State lead
Jeff Van Gundy came on the show and said
he agreed with Reggie your reaction to
that when you saw that or heard about
that I I saw and I disagree with both of
them I think first of all it's just to
be apps
be clear we did not suspend draymond
Green we upgraded an act on the floor to
a flagrant one as draymond has
acknowledged he put himself in that
situation by virtue of his is having
gotten a flagrant one he exceeded the
number of flagrant points you could get
throughout the playoffs and not get
suspended so in other words once he got
the flagrant one having already had
three flagrant foul points throughout
the playoffs that put him over the limit
and he was automatically suspended for
the next game and so then the question
becomes should we have not have given
him the flagrant one knowing that the
outcome would be for him to be suspended
and I can only imagine what people would
have said on the other side of the
argument had we not given the flagrant
when we saw an act enacted Raymond's
credit he acknowledged it there was no
dispute as to what happened the referees
did not see it on the floor there's also
no question they didn't they didn't see
it and decided and decide it wasn't a
flagrant they didn't see that act when
he swiped over at LeBron and hit him in
the groin area and that is a flagrant
our league I will say in the case of
draymond I think he knows it that he
wasn't about to get the benefit of the
doubt either based on his prior conduct
and and the purpose of that rule and and
and by the way I you know in terms of
Reggie you know just think I am fine
with the conversation if people want to
disagree with it but the theory behind
having in essence progressive discipline
by having it attacked in a cumulative
way was to disincentive got disincentive
guys from committing those acts over and
over again and it's one of the reasons
why we don't reset after every round of
the playoffs we don't want guys to think
all right I got a computer in so i can
get oh great now i can start over i'll
get a few play grants more as you know
that the genesis of these rules and by
the way for those who've been
criticizing these rules they've been in
place for about 20 years now and the
purpose of these rules was to cut down
on the amount of fighting on the floor
as you know from the old days in the NBA
fights used to break out all the time i
know you can have the images of david
stern courtside you know there's some
there's some great video of him where
players are spilling into the stands
other times where they're showing the
look on his face as players are swinging
punches at each other and the
idea was that's not there's no place in
our game for that and so what we one of
the ways we thought we could crack down
on that and I was at the league at the
time these rules were put in place was
too highly disincentivize guys from
committing flagrant fouls which you know
can lead to players retaliating and even
uh that dream on so called swype he even
acknowledges he's doing that in
retaliation physical grinding over is
the growing different though
commissioner and I'm not you know being
light-hearted with yes but but that area
is different than if he took a swipe at
his back or his knee or his ankle yeah
yes the head and groin are different and
always have been in this league and and
and you have to assume that there's a
reason to why players take shots at
other players groins or possibly their
head as opposed to a guy's back and and
even ten and I'd say where the where
dream on loses the benefited out here is
let's just say that and i'm not saying
dream on said this but lebron just
happened to turn at the last second and
he hit him in the groin instead of the
stomach or instead of the the shoulder
and the fact is he's now this has been
conduct its had that has been ongoing
throughout the playoffs and again that's
the purpose of these rules and it was
for us at the league office the last
thing we want to do of course is impact
the competition by suspending a player
especially during a fantastic finals
like this but we have to calm as we see
him and again I here Reggie and Jeff Van
Gundy but the notion we sit around the
league office yeah do we take a big gulp
and say what yeah we're adding up the
flavor points and well this is a
flagrant one that means they did for
that means he's get suspended of course
we're aware of that but he did I just
can only imagine if we had said yet he
did it but it's such a great matchup
with it's unfair to the fans to have to
lose an all-star player in the middle of
a great series like this we won't do it
there would have been just as much
outcry from the other side the
hack-a-shaq it's tough watching Tristan
Thompson go to the line and act like he
can shoot free-throws there we've seen
this with DeAndre Jordan and Andre
Drummond and I know that it's it's being
addressed right but but what would be a
simple solution to make basketball look
bad
did not have this this moment in the
game or games the simplest solution
would be to take the rule we now have an
effect for the last two minutes of the
game which by the way was put into
effect in 1978 so that this notion guys
got to make their free throws that line
was crossed you know more than 30 years
ago of the sense that you know you just
that's part of the game so therefore
just let guys shoot free throws
regardless of how bad they are but so
there was a decision made 1978 that to
change the rule for the last two minutes
you know where you you you know it's a
you can automatically go to the line and
take the ball out you know if you're
found if there's an intentional foul
away from the ball in the last two
minutes and you could take that rule and
put it in place for the entire game once
that I want to point out night I I
acknowledge I was on the fence on making
this change two years ago last summer I
said I was getting closer to thinking we
needed to do something but let's watch
another season and yet this season it's
up two and a half times again off last
season that the use of this technique is
up 16 times in the last five years but
one thing worth pointing out that even
in terms of some of those players you
just mentioned like DeAndre Jordan and
Dwight Howard big man who are
notoriously bad free-throw shooters
roughly two-thirds of the free throws
those guys still take involved plays
around the ball in other words i think
there's sometimes some confusion even
you probably remember this and went when
the expression hack-a-shaq was
originally coined it had to do with
fouling check every time he touched the
ball it wasn't go chase check to the
opposite end of the floor and found when
he has nothing to do with the play it
evolved to that but my only point being
that if a guy's a bad free-throw
free-throw shooter and he's still in the
game regardless of whether it's in the
last two minutes or any point in the
game the other team is still going to
look to foul that guy if they think
there's an advantage to putting him on
the line so you're still going to see
that what we'd love to do away with or
what I'd like to do away which is that
notion like like we saw Tristan Thompson
in the last game that the technique
speaker was using we're sending Barbosa
down all the way to the end of other end
of the court waving his hands waving his
hand look I'm grabbing among valium I
take that was not a traditional part of
the game
when the rule was changed in 1978 it had
become part of the game in the last two
minutes and it was eradicated but then
smart coach coaches analytics folks
others figured out there might be a
benefit to using at other points in the
game and that's what's happened I now
think that you know we need we need to
make the change it's just ugly I in
terms of the argument that guy's got to
make the free throws guys still will
need to make the free-throw there's
throws are still enormous incentive to
need to make your free throws because
again if you're a bad free-throw shooter
presumably the coaching the other team
is still going to instruct players at
certain key moments to try to foul that
guy and and lastly I think this is a
fascinating statistic over the course of
the last 50 years free throw percentages
in the league have remained it almost
exactly 75 percent it's almost it quite
you know counterintuitive you would
think with all the great coaching
techniques and analytics and new
approaches to shooting that somehow it
would be free throw shooting would have
gotten better over the years and it's
only it's one of the few apples to
apples comparisons you can make over
time because it's just a guy on a line
with the basketball trying to shoot a
free throw my only point in saying that
is that if we haven't that this notion
guys just got to get better shooting
free throws actually isn't borne out by
the data that bad free throw shooters
are going to be bad free throw shooters
and and in a league of 420 players or so
you're always going to have some bad
free-throw shooters and lastly i get for
some teams there's no doubt if you don't
have DeAndre Jordan if you don't have to
white Howard if you don't have one of
these guys who's a notoriously bad
free-throw shooter your view is I don't
want to change the rule because I'm
giving those teams and advantage and i
think that's that's the biggest obstacle
to changing the rule because teams
understandably want to vote their
self-interest and i'd only say there
that it we've looked at it up and down
without all the analytics people look at
it and it's only a very slight advantage
i think if we take away the rule it's
only a slight advantage to those teams
because it because it cuz once again
they're those guys are still going to
get fouled and key moments they just
have to be felled when they're in the
midst of a basketball play as opposed to
being on the other side of the floor
commissioner safe travels there and
enjoy the game and thanks for joining us
thanks man all right that's Adam Silver
NBA commissioner the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience